Right? I love that
fight. Marvel studios do.
Superheros are they?
If they run out of superheroes,
get this shit on my people at this rate.
I don't know who is this in Samuel
Jackson is a different superhero now. Who?
This is at the end of the Avengers movie.
Hey Samuel Jackson.
Say No to some captain marvel.
Well, who is, wait a minute.
Captain Marvel's a girl and she and
she brings all of them back to life.
Wait a minute. Who was captain marvel when
we were kids? Uh, dude, wait a minute.
I'll look. I don't know. It's
amazing that it's not a trans woman.
That would be dope. That's what
they're going to be enough trans.
Who's a weightlifting champion?
Come sit down and cheese.
No cheese. People get mad. People get the
cheese chewing on the microphone. Sued.
We're pros, man. You guys
are tear a couple of one,
two pros.
Cheesy dude.
If you didn't bring stuff in
provolone fresh. Okay. Okay. Hey,
how about this fight? [inaudible] Huseman
versus Tyron Woodley. I love that.
That's March 2nd. Come on it. He's
our second watch guys, come, come,
come to Vegas. Okay here. Captain
Marvel was a guy in a girl in the kid.
She was hot. They just picked
one. But that's from 2017 men.
This is when it's already been
diverse. 19 nine Captain Marvel, dude,
give me type in 1992
Spiderman and captain marvel.
1956 when I was about this, this
spider verse movie that just came out,
it's like only a four
year old Spiderman story.
It's if it's not some old
thing they brought back.
That's cute. That's a cartoon.
The captain captain. Marvel's old
school. No. Yeah, but what are those?
Spiderman is like a duck,
right? He's a pig bro.
It's a great movie.
Best movie I've seen in a long
term.
Bruce Lee into a superhero like powers.
My kids said Nate to the fucking legos
movie and when you want to see the lego
movie that played out,
it's good.
We've seen the other ones. My son loves
the Lego movie. Oh, it's the new one.
Both of them. A new one just came out.
How many have there been there? Only two.
Really. So cool. That Batman's a douchebag
girlfriend.
Right?
And then the girlfriend because Han Solo
pulls up in the Millennium Falcon and
mistake, wait a minute. This
is the old captain marvel,
but he was Zam Zam Zam also known as
captain marvel terms in marvelous.
She's dude, if you held a gun to my head
and asked me is Shizam DC or marvel?
I would have said cities DC for
sure. Yes, yes. Do you remember?
That's what I was trying to say.
There was a captain marvel character in
the DC comics universe from back then.
I don't know. That's what you remember
the marvel as one that existed.
So that's the confusion. That's
just an movie. Looks like.
Is it like someone from dela Torre
are fighting someone from the UFC?
It's confusing, dude. All I know,
she comes back and you know how
everyone died in the last one. Spoiler,
it's been up for an hour a year,
so fuck off.
She brings everyone back to
how the fuck she do that.
That's the comic books dude. Do you
remember in a Lego movie when Batman,
he leaves his girl to jump
in the Millennium Falcon
with Han Solo and Chewbacca,
and he says later,
so he jumped in,
he thought he was going to party like in
space, and then he comes back. They go,
what happened? He goes,
turns out that wilkies a dude
that was fucking hilarious.
There was no chicks because there there's
no chicks on the Millennium Falcon,
the android to to dig
marble 1968 but scroll down.
First appearance was the image
of a female. The girl 68 wow.
This picture from 2012
but here's the deal.
Girls weren't built like that back then.
They're building. It's a new thing now.
Those are you. Scroll down. Let me
see that image. That's all. I got.
A Primo crossfit chick. That's
legit. That's a new version of her.
Oh, that's 2012 yeah, that's a
UFC fighter chick. Right? Okay.
That's what they used to look like. Wow.
There's multiple captains on a marvel,
so captain marvel, sometimes a guy,
sometimes a girl. That goes both ways.
It goes both ways and you will know,
can relate to it. We're just like, hey,
whatever, whatever. But
they run a silver surfer.
There's so many superheros that they have
like 10 different ones on Netflix. Man.
A man,
shit,
fuck fucking Tommy wasp girl or some shit.
I can't fuck with that. Or aqua
man, get that shit out of me.
This is a good fight to Brian
Barbarina in [inaudible].
Luke K is a good fight if we didn't
watch miles jewelry. Let's be real. Oh,
this is a good fight now for sure.
This is a good one. That fight miles.
Jury did a few late. Did
feel, feel decision. Yes.
I didn't even watch the decision.
Well, we watched the flag.
We were taught the decision. Oh
Shit, Brian, but marina, good, right.